vous avez suivi tout cet après-midi
l'arrivée d'alexis navalni en russie
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter ces
derniers événements ces dernières heures
oui pas ces dernières heures dans un
premier temps il devait atterrir à
l'aéroport de vnoukovo où je me trouve
actuellement mais au dernier moment
alors que l'avion survolait la région il
a finalement été détournés vers
l'aéroport de cheremetievo et finalement
c'est à sheremetyevo que l'avion a
atterri
l'avion a atterri là pu en sortir de
façon libre enfin sortir de la bulle a
même accordé une courte interview aux
journalistes qui l'accompagnaient à bord
de l'avion une fois arrivé dans le
terminal
et c'est au moment de passer le contrôle
des passeports le contrôle de sécurité
qu'il a finalement été arrêté par les
autorités alors vous l'avez évoqué la
raison invoquée par la police c'est bien
une violation de sa période de probation
il est en effet jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 sous le coup d'une période
probatoire dans la sphère dans le cadre
d'une affaire de détournement de fonds
un tribunal qui a rendu un jugement une
condamnation de plusieurs années de
prison avec sursis
pour alexeï navalni et voilà il est
temps en allemagne il n'a pu répondre
aux obligations de cette paire de cette
période de probation et c'est donc pour
cette raison qu'il a été arrêté
quasiment dès son arrivée dès sa
descente de l'avion ici à moscou
merci beaucoup antoine claireaux